weeks and today's race couldn't be
bigger kevin martin joining us from the
track another loud place in las vegas
tonight kevin
yeah you got that right it is very loud
but it's worth it the playoffs are
underway here at the las vegas motor
speedway and fans are excited to be out
here i have run into william and carlo
and william how excited are you to be
out here today i'm extremely excited um
i can't wait and i just want to see kyle
bush win you know and tell me what did
you miss most about being out here at
the speedway this is the first time that
it's at 100 capacity um i miss all i
wanted i
sorry i miss all the people i like
watching nascar in real life now
and who do you think is going to win it
today kyle larson oh i like it and what
about you william kyle busch all the way
okay kyle bush the local we love it
thank you so much guys have some fun
today fans are out here 100 capacity as
i mentioned the motor speedway is
predicting that there will be upwards of
100 thousand visitors throughout the
entire weekend here reporting live at
the las vegas motor speedway emily
martin eight sports now